my film rebirth of a nation amusing
enough was a component in a show I had
at paula cooper gallery and one of the
things that really goes into my mind
when I think about contemporary art and
music is how weirdly divided they are
the art world likes music sort of but
when they do they usually go for sort of
like all white bread art rock they don't
get it you'll never see hip hop in
normal with me biennial or whatever I
mean they don't the art world has
problems with rhythm now at the same
time you have really interesting
electronic music and multicultural
specifically multicultural takes on
contemporary art my film rebirth of a
nation was a critique of the way Bush
had gotten into office playing off
racial politics and the fears that
whites have of being becoming a minority
and I think the code words for the Bush
administration people like Karl Rove was
that states rights and devolution of
federal powers would make these kind of
white now all of a sudden you notice
with the Obama administration they're
having a rise of all these white
militias and stuff like that yeah I mean
white Americans feel anxiety about some
of the issues and I think that that
needs to be addressed Birth of a Nation
the film by DW Griffith's is one of the
most important films in American history
it set the tone for how America views
racial politics in cinema so I got the
rights to the film we remixed it when i
say we i guess won't me and the whole
idea was to apply DJ technique to film
in a way that to kind of self implode
the film and get people to think about
it as a you know maybe something that
needs to be looked at a lot more closely
so with Bush you have to remember they
played games of the black vote they
disenfranchised a large amount of people
by playing those games and again it was
a lot of it happen in the Old South it
were places like Ohio so Birth of a
Nation was the first film to show a
flawed election and in 1915 I mean you
know a lot of games were being played
with the black vote so
disenfranchisement blackface you know if
you fast-forward and update it you could
easily see the same residence with
avatar where most of the main characters
were in blue face those were black
actors for example or Jar Jar Binks this
annoying creature that's like a minstrel
on the Star Wars thing
racial politics is still very much
prevalent in American film Terminator or
you know with the Transformers where
they have the kind of minstrel robots
who had this annoying black sort of
almost gave voice or something when I
said yeah I'm not no disrespect I'm just
saying it's a minstrel kind of damask
elated male voice where they're always
making black character like a jar jar
binks and annoying yeah what's up y'all
yeah you know it's kind of very annoying
creature or something like that that has
a high pitched and like yeah really
annoying like you know so anyway Birth
of a Nation what makes this an Arctic
project different than that is they're
both critiques of the nation states
relationship to the individual
Antarctica is the only place on earth
with no government it's the only place
that really says you are you the
subjectivity that goes into that we once
you step off a boat and you're on an ice
field in the middle of nowhere you are
without the idea of the nation state
anymore and I think Birth of a Nation
obviously nation you know nationalism
nation state the environmental politics
that go into how nations play with
carbon trading how nations play with the
idea of pollution and all these kinds of
things you could say that the divisions
now are even more encoded because if the
north-south divide like the
industrialized nations of the North
versus the more multicultural countries
of like China India Russia well Russia's
it's still considered European but if
you go slightly outside of you know
there's plenty of Russians that look
very Asian so um the racial politics
that go into environmental issues is
something that's hangs like a specter
over a lot of the process right now so I
had a big gallery show at robert miller
gallery called north south there was a
pun about my birth of a nation versus
antarctica sense of humor in the title
but nonetheless i'm very concerned about
the way environmental politics shapes
out with industrialized versus non
industrialized nations something really
we have to think about